In the US, the president is elected by the "Electoral College," with 538 votes distributed
about the population (for the most part) of the 50 States and Washington DC To become president, you have to
get the majority of the votes. But 538 is an even number, so what happens if there is one
of a draw?
No worries, there is an 18th century solution to this problem: If there is a tie at the 'Electoral College'
then the House of Representative breaks the tie.
As the name implies, the House is represented with delegates from every state. How
The more residents a state has, the more delegates it has with a total of 435 - thankfully
an odd number and therefore the possibility to break the tie. however, there is a snag: every delegate
does not get one vote, but every * State * gets one vote. So the 27 delegates from Florida
must mutually determine who they support before they cast Florida's vote
trying to break the tie.
In the meantime, the only delegates from sparsely populated Alaska only need to consult themselves
before he casts Alaska's vote.
This is an incredibly disproportionate system because only ten states, California, Texas,
New York, Florida, Illinois, Pennsylvania, Ohio, Michigan, Georgia, and North Carolina
houses more than half of the American population but only receives 20% of the votes
if there is a tie in the race for the presidency and the other 40 states with less than half the population
gets 80% of the votes.
Although an exact draw is unlikely, this system is also used if there are more than two candidates
to become president and none of them gets the majority in the 'Electoral College'.
What exactly happened when there were four candidates in 1824. Andrew Jackson
got the most votes from the Americans and in the 'Electoral College', but none
majority, so the result was then determined by the House of Representatives who voted as states
and chose John Quiny Adams instead.
In today's America with more states, a race with three candidates would give terribly disproportionate results.
Suppose there is a third (smaller) candidate who really likes the smaller states
and the smaller states love him mutually.
He gets the least votes in the 'Electoral College', but enough to be sure that neither one of them
more popular candidates get a majority so the House of Representatives must choose a winner - and the
26 smallest states representing only 17% of the population can appoint 'their' candidate as president
Although 83% of Americans did not vote for him.
It is unlikely, but it should not even be possible.
Anyway, because of all this talk about presidents, we have not yet mentioned the Vice President: a rational
person assumes that this is chosen together with the President, but no.
When there is a tie, the * Senate * independently chooses the Vice President leaving the US
can get a President from one party and a Vice President from the other party,
Which may cause very uncomfortable encounters.
But even this insane system to resolve draw is not watertight because there
100 members are in the Senate and the House of Representatives is obliged to vote as
50 states, and many of those states have 10 or 8 delegates representing the entire system
as leaky as a basket (due to the frequent occurrence of a draw), thanks to all even numbers.
So if the House of Representatives cannot elect a President but the Senate can choose a Vice President
the Vice-President acts when the President has been able to make a choice to the House of Representatives. But
If neither the House of Representatives can elect a President nor the Senate a Vice President
then the president of the House of Representatives becomes president until one part of Congress elects * someone *.
So this is the system by which the US resolves a draw in the race for the presidency,
despite the fact that it may be faster (a fairer) to just throw a coin in.
Of course you could get rid of the 'Electoral College, and therefore this insane system
and instead hold national elections, perhaps even with something chic like preferential votes
but that's just a crazy idea.